خبره رفيعه مستوى اجتمعت في القاهره
لمناقشه شركه السعوديه المصريه لحمايه
الامن القومي العربيه اليمن نموذجا والتي
ناقشت عدد من الاوراق البحثيه الهامه في
هذا الشان منها ما كان معنيا بالتدخلات
الخارجيه وحمايه الوطن العربيه منها
تهديدات ايرانيه في اليمن لكل المنطقه
العربيه وبالذات السعوديه
جديده
[موسيقى]
الصين في الموضوع
لانشرين لها وضع كبير الندوه تستهدفت في
واحده من اوراقها اهميه مشروع مسام لازاله
الالغام ولكن هذا الموضوع عرج بالحديث على
عدد من الالغام الاكثر اهميه من وجهه نظر
المشاركين
امريكا وبين ايران بس الواحد لما يتامل
المساله بعمق جدا يجب انه تم دعم للايه
للجهود الايرانيه في تفكيك المنطقه عمليه
التفكيك هذه احنا لابد ان احنا ننظر اليه
على انها انغام بتظهر في جسد العروبه
التوصيات تمارك حول ضروره استخدام اوراق
الضغط العربيه لوضع اليمن على راسها
الاولويات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
النيه عندها اوراق ضغط حقيقيه
متخصصه من القوات المسلحه المصريه
والسعوديه
لرفع الالغام في المناطق التي يتفق عليها
تحت مظله الجامعه العربيه
وتختر كل الاطراف المعنيه بانها مستعده
للبدل فورا في رفع هذه
القتال اولا قبل الحديث عن ازاله الالغام
والا سيكون امرا لا ينتهي تامر نصره
العربيه القاهره